1 rovello rettore dice che è qui da un
di atti non ci posso credere mi fa
strano
incredibile abbiamo tolto tutti i
preconcetti possiamo fare video del
saggio di ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
nuovo look e tino e guarda avanti però è
che
questo un blog un po particolare perché
io dico giampiero stiamo andando ad
aquafan e l'acqua fa lo conoscete anche
per il video di capri fonte oggi vedrete
una bellissima giornata all'acquafan tra
l'altro e se lo chiudono apposta non è
vero no è vero ciò che è una posta ma
faremo il video per gli scivoli saranno
solo per noi che fantastico quindi ci
godremo un po tutto quanto che speriamo
di arrivare vivi innanzitutto perché
guido io e poi appena arriviamo vi
facciamo vedere tutto quanto quindicina
tra poco
allora è scemo 60 e girato ce l'abbiamo
fatta the like perché siamo
sopravvissuti che si fa oggi e non lo so
non pensavo di arrivare fino a questo
punto siamo alla botanica allora io
primissima cosa brocchi di denunce la
prima insieme a cosa io toglierei la
musica di sottofondo che so niente non
copia e quindi continuerò a parlare per
non farla sentire visto molto che
quest'anno mani maxibon me ne prendi uno
meno amari chimere colpi 2
simon un altro secondo me deve altre le
velocità non ho un sacco di fama anche
abbassare peraltro passiamo la voce non
fa male non si sente il copyright a
queste di maximum qua abbiamo
preferito ma vedo due questo qua che il
blog blog gara man mamma mia
ragazzi primo scivolo di oggi hanno
chiuso il parco e stiamo utilizzando il
parco chiuso che è una figata c'era un
feedback è stato infatti quest'arena
allora
no quello giallo allora ragazzi questo è
un video mostrano non sommate sui miei
piedi quadruplo piede quando vuoi caro
arrivederci
si no
in pezzi impressioni aprendo no no no io
ragazzi cioè io avevamo tutto questo
però pensavo che fossero
ai duemila all'ora bellissimo ragazzi
veramente figo signori avremo la cappa
di giampiero in questo secondo scivolo
grazie ai rami tirato una testata sulle
palco no io dico giampiero
arrivederci
banca banca rivederti
[Musica]
ecco ecco
ecco al contrario anche no bastò una
parte il controllo non ci sono io mi
toglierei di qua fuori non sono tempo
primi due mandati
adesso sta usa teatret intermezzo
pubblicità alla ragazzi siamo
all'acquafan appunto per il maximum dei
e abbiamo il tar barry al noi camera
mela adesso se giampiero spa la cortesia
mi bendano anzi dipenda valori e io devo
indovinare quale dei due e volendo ok
quindi mayank barry o blog cara ma ora
mi fai assaggiare un tuo piede io so
sembra un caravan e
bravissimo posso dire una cosa e secondo
me va beh secondo me l'acquapark tutto
per noi è molto più bello beh allora è
un po come quando giochi a profilo di
world se c'è nessun altro che giocano e
meglio perché almeno vinci sicuro ciao
ermanno ermanno il mio personal manager
introduce di alla gente che non ti
conosce ciao sono nuovo personale va
bene così
permane troppo bello signore ermanno è
il nuovo sex symbol sul canale prima poi
abbiamo il buon giampiero giusto per
fare contratto sto scherzando
ragazzi quello che amo io di questo
lavoro è l'imprevedibilità che un giorno
come meta certo lorenzo buongiorno o il
buon e armando
e ci ficca perché rischio rapida non è
vero perché l'acqua fan e di ardente
solo che io ricordo per niente la pro
mondo e terribili quindi questa cosa che
sto facendo tutti questo questo persino
non è per fare il figo e per togliere la
testa dal ragazzi addosso interamente
quello che farei
[Musica]
a
va bene ragazzi
prossimo schiphol come se non bastasse
però derby allora adesso senza fare cose
serie
perché tutti quindi mette allora questo
aspetto è un po più agonistico chi vince
si piglia il maxibon è un'altra cosa non
abbraccio stritolante da questo ragazzo
proprio lui per la visitazione
a posto siamo su quello per bambini
perché va tre volte quello normale
arriva molto più veloce il problema è
che molto probabilmente lorenzo perderà
perché lui deve tenere il cellulare
quindi questo è un vero problema però fa
niente al 31
[Musica]
bene
oddio
la piantina la libertà
ma vaffan
ammazzati non vale avevo il telefono sai
che ti guarda che era tutta una tattica
che ci chiede sprigionare lui male come
pronti però è pronto le discipline mai
fatti vedere fagli vedere scritto no
spesso questo prima del sì questo prima
del prossimo scivolo l'attenzione alla
congestione che è quello in cui spero
per aver barato però perché io c'è una
cosa un vero amico a differenza tua e
dopo questo scivolo se lo dividiamo va
bene se vinco 16 cosa
ok
si vede niente ma stiamo scendendo non
si vede niente ma siamo certi che è
sicuro io stiamo sentendo è orribile ma
che non si vede nulla oddio
[Musica]
schemi marcarli lakota
poi guarda dove il gommone tutto a posto
il tuo motorino mi grazie maxibon per la
moto non fare anche per anche per i
gelati ma per la moto ma la rega ma
regalo
[Musica]